you resisted doing a movie for 10 years
and you you know and you were honest you
said listen guys i don't want any more
concussions i don't want to go through
it anymore
yet you were
writing down ideas for 10 years and you
came up with all of these crazy how many
concepts did you come up for this film
if i got an idea i would
type i would put jackass 4 in the
subject line and email it to myself
right then
right and so i did that for 10 years and
i didn't know if i wanted to do another
movie not because of concussions or not
i just didn't feel
i didn't have that feeling of like
i i really need to do another movie and
but all that time i knew that i should
keep writing just in case and then
i don't know around
2018
i started to get that overwhelming
feeling
that
i wanted to do another one then i
couldn't
stop my thoughts until i had to get jeff
tremaine and pull him in for a meeting
and you know
it was in 2018 my father
my mother passed away in 2017 and
my dad was really sick in 2018
and
i just left tennessee
after i saw him and a couple days later
my sister was like you need to come back
dad's taking a turn for the worse
and my dad loved jackass he loved it
and
i had made a decision that i wanted to
do another one but i hadn't told anyone
and dad was going to be the first person
i told
the plane lands and my sister's like how
far away are you and i said about 12
minutes
and i get to the hospital my sister
meets me outside
and
her head drops and she starts crying
and she said dad just passed
and
it was crushing to me because i just
wanted to see him and tell him that uh
i loved him and we're doing an another
film and how happy that would have made
him
so
that was tough
that was tough
uh i still think about it
that i didn't get to tell him
but he knew i loved him